Das ist der Militärmusikfestival Rap-Blick
von Informationsoffizier John Patrick Platzer
Ich melde mich zum Dienst – der Auftrag ist klar
„Fürs Militärmusikfestival - wieder viral“
Auch dieses Jahr hat mich das
Bundesheer ins Rennen geschickt
Klar - alle uniform – doch nur ich hab den Drip.
Mit Platzkonzerten - ging die Party los
Wir machten 16 Mal Station für musikalische Shows
In Kärnten, Steiermark
Slowenien - Salzburg – Tirol
Man konnte auch Informationen
übers Bundesheer hol‘n
Zum Beispiel – gibt's beim Heer – vielfältige Jobs
manche sind unbeirrt sogar
vom Sprungturm gedropped,
absolvierten versiert, einen Ninja Parkour
die Militärmusik - on fleek – Heer on Tour
Auch das Jagdkommando - oder IKT Cyber
Ein Eurofighter- Pilot -
bei den Shows mit dabei war
Du willst noch mehr Infos - als dieses Rap-Resümee
Dann klick dich rein auf musik.bundesheer.at
Ich freue mich euch hier in Kärnten zu sehn
In der 28 Black Arena, die Crème de la Crème
Am 25. Mai wird ein besonderer Tag
Mit nem besondren Länderspiel, der besonderen Art
Zum Beispiel kommen Abordnungen aus Slowenien an
Auch aus Italien, Montenegro und auch dem Oman
Über 700 Musiker und -innen am Start
Überraschungen parat, ich
komme grad erst in Fahrt.
Mission Vorwärts: Ja, das
musikalische Line Up - das is mega
vor allem mit Hits von Chartstürmer - Chris Steger
Autogramm-Jäger haben einiges vor
auch Andreas Schager - singt was vor – Heldentenor
Nicht nur Bergbauernbuam,
freuen sich dann vor Glück
wenn die entzückende Lederhosenrockerin anrückt
aus dem Lesachtal direkt zum Wörther See
Naschenweng Melissa – 10 von 10
Es geht ums Herz, weil Licht
ins Dunkel am Start ist
Die Spenden sind wertvoll
und die Tickets sind gratis
Also – kommt vorbei! - Die Party geht ab!
Zugsführer John Patrick Platzer – meldet sich ab!